Des montagnes d'émeraude,
un marché important en Colombie,
plus de 300 millions
de dollars par an.
Un commerce qui a engendré
la violence et le sang.
Cette année,
il y a le bois de fraises.
Le roi de l'émeraude,
c'est lui, Don Victor Carranza,
le plus gros producteur
et négociant du monde.
Quinze gardes du corps autour de lui.
On ne sait jamais.
Ces dernières années,
la guerre de l'émeraude
a fait plus
de 4000 morts en Colombie
et attirait les convoitises
des cartels de la drogue.
Don Victor Carranza,
homme pressé, se rend à la mine
dans un
de ces trois hélicoptères.
Mousseau, l'une
des nombreuses mines de Don Victor.
C'est là qu'il a commencé,
à l'âge de neuf ans, il y a 50 ans.
Les pierres, Don Victor
aime bien les sortir lui-même.
La mine,
c'est toute la vie de Don Victor Carranza.
Parti de rien et classé aujourd'hui
parmi les 20 premières fortunes mondiales
par le magazine Forbes,
le roi de l'émeraude
n'a qu'une passion,
les fermes,
les troupeaux et les chevaux.
Je connais
par ailleurs ce que vous faites
avec votre poulailler à la ferme.
La mine de Mousseau,
la plus connue de Colombie
pour les émeraudes.
35 000 personnes en permanence,
parmi elles, de nombreux enfants.
10 h par jour,
la sueur et la peine.
Accrochés aux montagnes autour,
les favelas des chercheurs d'émeraude.
C'est là qu'habite Pedro,
ses deux frères et sa famille.
L'année dernière,
ça a bien marché,
on a trouvé quelques émeraudes
cette année on n'a rien trouvé,
alors on ne mange pas notre faim.
Il y a deux ans, j'ai trouvé
deux petites émeraudes
qui se sont bien vendues.
Elles étaient jolies
car égales l'une à l'autre
mais elles étaient toutes petites,
minuscules.
J'ai huit ans et tous les jours
je travaille à la mine
pour m'en sortir
et aider à la maison.
Victor Carranza, Don Victor,
comme on l'appelle ici,
est le propriétaire
de la mine de Mousseau.
Presque chaque jour,
au moment où les enfants vont travailler,
Don Victor descend de sa forteresse
entourée de barbelés, la mine du haut.
C'est dans ces favelas
que Don Victor est né il y a 59 ans.
Pour lui, redescendre ici,
à la mine des pauvres,
c'est comme une nécessité.
Il y a 50 ans,
c'était déjà comme aujourd'hui.
J'étais comme eux,
comme ces gosses.
Nous étions des familles nombreuses,
de 8 à 10 enfants
et il fallait aider à la maison.
Alors quand on a cinq ans,
tu comprends vite
le travail à la Mine.
Où chercher ?
Où trouver ?
Ces enfants que vous voyez ici
tentent leur chance,
cherchent fortune
comme je l'ai fait moi-même.
Cette année les émeraudes
ne se laissent pas prendre,
mais si je pouvais en trouver une,
j'achèterais un peu de viande.
Quand je ne trouve rien
pour manger,
je vends des limonades,
des bières
et je me fais moins
de 2 000 Pesos par jour.
Là-haut sur la mine de Don Victor
qui fonctionne 24 h sur 24,
tout est exploitée méthodiquement,
avec des moyens très importants.
La recherche se fait en surface
et en sous-sol.
Lorsque les tonnes de terre
ont été traitées,
on les rejette à coups de bulldozer
dans la vallée.
C'est dans ces déchets,
"le tembré" comme on l'appelle ici,
que se concrétisent ou se défont
les rêves des chercheurs d'en bas
les cuaqueros.
Les jours de fête Don Victor qui
connaît la misère des cuaqueros
envoie dans la vallée
plus de "tembrés"
pour augmenter
leurs chances de trouver des pierres.
Avec mon frère ainé,
on prenait nos pelles
et on cherchait des émeraudes.
Comme il avait
plus d'expérience que moi,
il vendait
les pierres que je trouvais.
Ma surprise a été grande.
Mon frère aîné
a vendu une pierre 30 Pesos.
Une demi-heure plus tard,
j'ai vu la personne
qui l'avait acheté
la revendre 50 Pesos.
J'ai compris que
c'était plus intéressant d'acheter
et de vendre les pierres
que de les chercher.
J'ai donc laissé l'appel
et me suis consacrée au négoce.
Une légende
bien ancrée dit qu'un jour
quelqu'un a trouvé
une émeraude de 100 000 $.
De partout,
les gens sont arrivés,
y compris
les petits négociants de Bogota
qui viennent aussi
chercher la grosse pierre
qu'ils ne trouveront jamais.
Pour tous les cuaqueros,
mais surtout pour les enfants
Don Victor est un véritable mythe.
Parti de rien comme eux,
il est arrivé tout en haut
et possède aujourd'hui
des montagnes d'émeraude.
Le rêve concrétisé
de tous les gens d'en bas.
Don Victor à commencer ici
comme nous, avec la pelle,
et il a trouvé
une grosse émeraude.
Alors il a acheté cette mine.
Puis avant lui,
il y avait un autre propriétaire,
mais il a été assassiné
et c'est Don Victor qui a repris la mine.
Je veux trouver une pierre grosse
comme ça pour être riche
et racheter
les mines de Don Victor.
On peut toujours rêver,
ça ne coûte rien.
Dans la vie,
il faut être ambitieux.
On a compris que pour réussir,
il fallait acheter
les actions des mines en exploitation.
Ce que nous avons fait.
On a mis six ans
pour trouver le filon,
mais pendant six ans,
on n'a rien trouvé.
Rien.
Lorsqu'un filon est trouvé,
Don Victor aime bien extraire
lui-même les émeraudes.
Ma vie c'est la famille,
mais c'est aussi
extraire les émeraudes.
Je mourrais ici.
En principe Don Victor
autorise ses gardes du corps
à ramasser quelques pierres.
Les gardes du corps seulement.
Gare à celui
qui ne comprend pas.
Être ouvrier dans les mines de Don Victor,
c'est un privilège.
Les gens d'en bas
se battent pour y arriver.
Pousse-toi, recule.
Fou le camp.
Ça suffit, si tu ne m'obéis pas,
vas à l'administration.
Va voir avec elle,
je ne veux plus de toi ici.
À 13 h 01 quart d'heure
pour déjeuner seul.
À Mousseau, on cherche au-dessus,
on cherche aussi dessous.
Pour Don Victor, milliardaire
qui pourrait gérer sa fortune
sur un yacht dans les Caraïbes,
la mine est un besoin.
Certains jours,
il reste plus de 6 h au fond
avec les mineurs.
Lorsqu'une veine est repérée,
c'est Don Victor lui
même qui allume les mèches.
Alors faites-le Joseph Worth.
L'explosion est forte,
ouvrez la bouche pour la décompression.
Victor Carranza a
pour les émeraudes
un véritable flair,
un instinct presque infaillible
qui prend le pas sur la science
et les avis des géologues.
Voyons, par ici,
on va continuer tout droit
jusqu'à l'autre filon.
Peut-être en tournant,
on arriverait plus vite au filon.
Non, on va tout droit.
Don Victor Carranza,
contrôle aujourd'hui
35 % de la production mondiale,
70 % des mines
d'émeraudes de Colombie,
les plus belles du monde,
aux dires des spécialistes.
"Il y aura besoin, mon œil,
qu'on emballe maintenant la tendresse".
"Oui, ça te vient
de Salama Kida".
Si j'ai réussi,
c'est parce que je suis venu vivre,
dormir, travailler
à la mine toute l'année.
Car ici, même si l'on paye
un administrateur 20 000 $ par mois,
la tentation est trop forte
et sûr, il volera.
Sorti de la mine dont Victor,
homme pressé,
se jette dans l'un
de ses trois hélicoptères,
son mulet comme il l'appelle.
Les mines de Mousseau sont
à deux jours de voiture de Bogota.
Une demi-heure en hélicoptère.
Ce jour-là, Don Victor est venu
à Bogota avec ses gardes du corps
pour une négociation importante.
Tellement de sacrifices pour finalement
jeter ces cailloux sur la table.
Messieurs,
on vous a préparé ces lots par taille,
mais si vous voulez,
mélangez-les.
Mais oui, c'est bien ça,
va falloir prendre autre chose.
Eux, ce sont
des acheteurs colombiens.
Merci.
23 736 carats.
Le prix minimum
est de 10 millions de dollars.
Il me faut une réponse,
vite.
On propose 7 millions.
Non.
Tu essaies de m'avoir ou quoi ?
On voit que ce n'est pas
toi qui descends à la mine.
Bon, le minimum
c'est 8 millions de dollars.
C'est d'accord,
on accepte le marché,
8 millions de dollars
négociés en cinq minutes.
Celui qui achète
les pierres en brut,
ne sait jamais
ce qu'il va obtenir après la taille.
Il prend le risque
de gagner ou de perdre.
C'est l'enjeu, le pari.
C'est ça le mystère des pierres.
Personne ne percera le secret.
En taillant la pierre,
on enlève les impuretés
et on évite de perdre trop de poids.
Mais la pierre taillée gagne
en qualité et en valeur.
Par exemple,
cette pierre de 40 carats
perd 60 % de son poids.
On obtient une pierre
de 16 carats d'une qualité supérieure.
La plus belle pierre de ce lot,
c'est celle-ci.
Elle est d'excellente qualité.
Sa cristallisation est exceptionnelle.
Le verre est
d'une pureté incroyable.
Vert citron comme on dit ici.
Elle coûte ?
250 000 $.
La plus belle pierre,
c'est la prochaine.
Nous satisfaisons
la vanité du monde.
Puerto Lopez, capitale des Lianos,
la région de la pampa colombienne,
le deuxième fief de Don Victor.
Ici, avec l'argent des émeraudes,
ils achètent des fermes
les unes après les autres.
Ici en Colombie,
celui qui a de l'argent,
qui a réussi est menacé
par la délinquance commune
et par la guérilla.
Alors quand je vais
dans mes propriétés et mes fermes
pour ne pas tomber
dans les filets de la guérilla
qui risque de m'enlever, me rançonner,
de m'assassiner facilement,
je me déplace
avec mon groupe de sécurité.
Le groupe
de protection de Don Victor,
c'est quinze hommes armés,
attachés nuit et jour à sa personne.
Mais son autre vraie passion,
c'est le cheval.
ici on peut acheter
un hectare de terre pour 35 francs.
C'est le prix
d'un Coca-Cola en Europe.
Je mets une tête de bétail
par hectare de terre.
C'est ma marque,
le V de Vitor.
Le C de Carranza.
Combien l'hacienda possédez-vous ?
Environ 35.
Combien d'hectares en tout ?
Je ne sais pas, 220 000.
Victor Carranza parti de rien,
est aujourd'hui classé
dans les 20 premières fortunes mondiales
par le magazine américain Forbes.
Son seul vrai caprice,
son cheval papillon.
Valeur 12 millions de francs.
C'est son cheval préféré.
Ce cheval Don Victor ne le monte
qu'accompagné de ses musiciens.
Dans chacune
des haciendas de Victor Carranza,
il y a un point d'atterrissage
pour hélicoptère.
Ces fermes lui rapportent
beaucoup d'argent.
Les ventes de bétail
sont très importantes.
À chaque fois qu'il le peut,
Don Victor achète
une nouvelle ferme,
parfois sur la carte,
sans même l'avoir vue.
Omniprésent,
les gardes du corps veillent.
On ne sait jamais.
À Bogota, tandis que Don Victor
conforte son empire des Llanos
en achetant toutes les fermes
qu'il peut acheter,
Carlos Castilla,
son homme de confiance,
parcourt
la rue numéro treize,
celle du petit
commerce des émeraudes.
Sentir le marché,
prendre le pouls des cours,
c'est aussi son rôle, même si l'endroit
n'a pas toujours bonne réputation.
Cette rue est dangereuse
pour vous les étrangers.
Il y a beaucoup de voleurs,
d'escrocs
qui essaient de vendre
des fausses pierres, du verre,
des pierres peintes,
des pierres synthétiques.
Il y a beaucoup d'arnaques.
Le vrai commerce d'émeraudes
se fait là-haut, dans les immeubles.
Même si pas mal d'argent est brassé
ici, Carlos Castilla a raison.
Le vrai commerce des émeraudes
se fait à l'abri des regards
dans des endroits où quantité
et qualité vont souvent de pair.
Don Carlos, cette pierre,
nous l'avions négociée
à 3 millions de pesos par Carat
et maintenant il nous
en demande 8 millions.
Don Carlos,
cette pierre est magnifique.
Regardez ce verre, cet éclat
et bien sûr cette vie qu'elle renferme.
Ils en demandent 100 000 $.
On va essayer
de l'acheter 60 000 $.
Chez Cartier,
cette pierre vaut 250 000 $.
Moi, je leur vendrai
approximativement 100 000 $.
Les masses d'argent brassées
par le commerce d'émeraudes,
ont évidemment et depuis
longtemps attirées des convoitises.
Entre autres, les cartels
de la drogue s'y sont intéressés
pour le blanchiment de l'argent.
Aujourd'hui, l'argent des émeraudes
n'a pas toujours bonne réputation.
Tu peux prendre un billet
dans la poche de Don Victor.
Cet argent n'est pas sale.
Il représente
les larmes et la sueur.
Ils ont voulu le mêler
injustement au trafic de drogue.
Ceux qui le connaissent bien
peuvent dire que c'est absurde.
La guerre verde
4000 morts en quatre ans.
Le point culminant de cette guerre,
c'est l'assassinat de Gilberto Molina
et de ses 18 gardes du corps,
le dimanche 26 janvier 1989.
Molina, c'était l'associé
de Don Victor.
C'est Gonzalo Rodriguez Garcia,
qui a fait assassiner Gilberto,
mon associé.
On a tous été obligés de réagir.
Car, Gilberto était mon grand ami,
notre leader, notre frère.
Pour contrer les attaques
de Rodriguez Garcia
qui veut prendre
le contrôle de ces mines,
Victor Carranza va investir
d'énormes sommes d'argent
dans la guerre de l'émeraude.
En fait, c'est l'armée colombienne
qui abattra Rodriguez Garcia,
bras armé
du cartel de Medellin,
qui veut s'emparer
des mines d'émeraudes
pour blanchir
l'argent de la cocaïne.
Les familles d'exploitants
et de négociants, petits ou gros,
vont se livrer
une lutte sans merci
dont sortiront
seulement quelques survivants.
Je les ai reconnus.
C'étaient
les hommes du Pékinois.
Le Pékinois, le voici,
entouré de ses gardes du corps.
Longtemps opposé
à d'autres Victor Carranza,
ils se sont
aujourd'hui réconciliés.
Je voudrais que les autres
tiennent à savoir également.
Ex-frères ennemis
Victor Carranza
et Louis Murcia, alias le Pékinois,
se rencontrent maintenant assez
fréquemment avec leurs pistoleros
dans un climat étrange.
Il y a eu
beaucoup de violences,
beaucoup
de morts des deux côtés.
Alors j'ai parlé
avec le Pékinois,
ou on continuait la guerre,
ou on faisait la paix.
Plutôt que de continuer
à se faire la guerre,
les partis se sont aujourd'hui associés
et ont croisé leurs actions
des mines d'exploitation d'émeraude
dans une société qui s'appelle Esm Rascol.
Dans ces formes curieuses
d'assemblée générale
derrière des portes closes,
tous les associés se partagent
plusieurs millions
de dollars de pierres.
Je n'ai pas
le temps d'être acquéreur.
Il en manque une, recomptez.
Ça aussi,
c'est une découverte magnifique.
Si Victor Carranza
et le Pékinois
laissent quelques membres
de leurs troupes
toucher de près
ces énormes émeraudes
et profitaient de leur partage,
ce n'est pas
seulement par générosité.
Il y a longtemps
qu'ils ont appris
à se méfier
de tout et de tous.
Ils savent bien
que les infidélités de certains pistoleros
ont coûté quelques vies
à pas mal de leurs amis.
Quelques pierres valent bien mieux
que des balles de révolver.
Plus les pierres sont grosses,
plus la fidélité sera grande.
J'ai quatorze ans
et je viens d'avoir Irigoyen
lorsque je suis survenu
dans une soirée dans les valises.
Ce que j'aime dans ce scénario,
c'est attraper
une carte de telle ou telle belle.
Non, 671 grammes ce lot,
non dites-nous a un prix
et nous, on réfléchit.
Entre Victor et le Pékinois,
cette forme de paix raisonnée
est revendiquée aujourd'hui
par chacun d'entre eux.
Celles-ci sont très belles.
Ça a été très dur.
Je ne veux pas
me souvenir de la guerre.
Il faut vivre le présent
et penser au futur.
Celui qui a proposé la paix,
c'est moi, Louise Murcia,
Don Victor Carranza l'a acceptée.
C'était villages contre villages,
familles contre familles.
Don Victor a eu un rôle essentiel
dans le processus de paix.
Aujourd'hui, Don Victor
a un dernier rêve à satisfaire
la création d'une bourse mondiale
de l'émeraude en Colombie.
Une fois pour toutes,
Victor Carranza, parti de rien,
voudrait ainsi faire oublier
certains chemins tortueux
de son itinéraire
et acquérir les vraies lettres
de noblesse du roi de l'émeraude.